Ilhan Omar's defenders castigate speech
as incitement Michael moulds is attacked
at a speech no I didn't hire the guy and
we checked the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show I know and
I found out that Michael Mills was
attacked last night at a speech my first
thought was well thank God and then I
found out he was okay no it's like
dammit if I hire somebody to do a job
you just can't get good people to do
things these days you got to do
everything yourself so when he gets back
to LA I'm just gonna go out there with a
super soaker filled with bleach and go
after him we'll get to all that just hit
first
attention gun lovers how would you like
to hit the range tomorrow with a brand
new gun I know I would and the United
States concealed-carry Association wants
to make that dream come true for you
they are here to help train and protect
responsible gun owners like you and me
and right now they're giving away not
one not two but 19 free guns so what
type of gun will it be
well here are some hints to start it is
one of the world's most popular
double-action pistols on planet Earth
today it's often the choice of the gun
of choice for law enforcement officer
civilians and our military its accuracy
makes it an ideal concealed carry gun
and it can even be used as a perfect
training gun right out of the box this
sound like something you'd want I know
that I would simply text the word win
287 2 2 2 right now to reveal the
identity of this gun and instantly lock
in your 19 free chances to win it that's
WI n 287 - 2 - it's simple quick 100%
free Oh extra bonus the first 3,000
people to text in will also be sent a
free concealed carry guide just for
entering so you really have nothing to
lose pretty awesome your opportunity is
slipping away this giveaway does end
soon so text the word win - 8 7 - 2 -
right now for the official rules lock in
your 19 entries and get your free
concealed carry guide before it is too
late
text win - 8 7 - 2 - that is wi n - 8 7
- 2 - alrighty so we begin today with
the continuing fallout over Ilhan Omar
getting herself into trouble once again
because it is a day ending in Y and a
month with more than 17 days so that
means that ohon Omar is in trouble again
and she's doubling down on her being in
trouble because she is not good at this
also she's not a very good person so
there are a few different things that
are wrong with Ilhan Omar's take on 9/11
so she begins that this all came to
light over the past few days because she
was speaking at the Council on
american-islamic relations who played
the clip several times
and while she was there she suggested
that care was founded in the aftermath
of 9/11 not true to defend Muslims after
some people did something and people
were who remember 9/11 were said to
themselves what now some people did
something that's that's you're hot take
some people did something and she
defended this not by suggesting that she
may have been insensitive in her remarks
or that's not what she meant
or obviously 9/11 was a truly terrible
tragedy for the country and an act of
tremendous evil all the things that you
would expect a person to say in this
position instead she simply keeps
doubling down on all of this like over
and over and over again so for example
Ilhan omar tweeted out this morning she
tweeted out this morning in response to
all of this quote the people and the
people who knocked these buildings down
will hear from all of us soon president
george w bush was bushed downplaying the
terrorist attack what if he was a Muslim
what in the living hell is that supposed
to mean first off let's analyze that
quote from President Bush I remember him
saying that you remember him saying that
if you are older than 17 years old
because he was standing on the rubble of
Ground Zero at the time with a bullhorn
and explaining to people that the people
who perpetrated the attack would soon be
dead because we would be sending our
soldiers overseas to kill them that's
what he meant by that the people who
knocked those buildings down will hear
from all of us soon was not him saying
we're going to call them and then have a
nice conversation and that was not that
was not the idea the idea was the evil
people who knocked down these buildings
are going to hear from us in the form of
missiles was pushed down playing the
terrorist attack no you do he wasn't
downplaying the terrorist attack and I
love her take what if he was a Muslim
right the real victims the real victims
of 9/11 were the Muslims obviously the
real victims of 9/11 across the United
States were Muslims now I am old enough
to remember all of this going down and
the media's chief concern one of their
chief concerns in the aftermath of 9/11
was the so-called Islamophobic backlash
which did not end up materializing
there's a lot of worry about Muslims
being mistreated across the country that
did not end up materializing and George
W Bush went out of his way over and over
and over to separate Islam from the
terrorists I think
he went overboard by characterizing
Islam as a religion of peace for example
I don't think he's an Islamic scholar so
I don't think that he had the expertise
to do that but he obviously was
attempting to protect innocent Muslims
from being lumped in with radical
Muslims who'd committed terrorist
atrocities and yet Ilhan Omar continues
with this narrative that Muslims were
truly victimized on 9/11 as opposed to
the people who were murdered in the 9/11
terror attacks so you want to prove that
you are sympathetic to the victims of
9/11 and your first response to all of
this is to downplay 9/11 again by
suggesting that if he that the real
issue here is whether Bush was treated
differently because he was not a Muslim
guy what in the living hell now most
Democrats are running for the hills
they're nowhere to be found they won't
comment on this stuff the reason they
won't comment on this stuff is because
they are afraid of taking off the fresh
faces of the Democratic Party you know
the ones who are drawing all the
attention Ilhan Omar Rashida Talib
Alexandra Ocasio Cortes who have formed
the three dragons of the radical left
and most Democrats are refusing comments
on this they're running for the hills
they don't want anything to do with the
comments but they also don't want to
tick off these three young women who are
the new fresh faces so fresh so face of
the Democratic Party a couple exceptions
there is a top Democrat named Liu Jian
who came out and said yeah this is not
great stuff this is this is you know she
needs to do better than that statements
were not only hurtful to me but
extremely hurtful to everyone that was
personally impacted by those terrorist
attacks
no one should refer to what happened on
9/11 with terrorist attacks that killed
thousands of Americans as something by
some people okay now that person is the
assistant Speaker of the US House of
Representatives
representative Bennett rate Lucien from
New Mexico now he is obviously right but
you're not hearing this overwhelmingly
from the Democratic Party instead what
you're mostly hearing in the media is
all of Ilhan Omar's radical friends
including anti-semites like Rasheeda
Talib and anti-semite fellow travelers
like AOC come out and defend
Ilhan Omar because there's the new
diverse freshman class ooh
so here's Rasheeda Talib suggesting that
the real problem here is that people
don't
like Ilhan Omar because she is a Somali
woman of Muslim who is a Muslim I'm not
for policing people you know that's what
they're doing to us women of color I
mean think about it this is a diverse
class they've never had two Muslim women
they never had a palestinian-american
they've never had a woman that was at
refugee I mean these are real-life
impactful stories that come with us
because our lens is so different you
know this is not just about a congress
that looks differently but we serve
differently and we talk about these
issues differently but it's an
institution that it just is not ready
for people like us
oh that's it it must be it must be the
color of skin or the character of of
genitalia it must be that you're a
female or that you are Muslim or that
you have a darker shade darker hue of
skin color it must be that not the open
anti-semitism bill you and illa hanim
are repeatedly engaging it can't be that
Omar is a radical on foreign policy
which she is Muslim or not she's a
radical on foreign policy I will show
you the evidence of this in just one
second but it must be that the criticism
is all it's all related to race now
weird because there are other Muslims in
the US Congress and they don't receive
this kind of criticism because they
don't say this kind of crap there are
other black people there are other
people who are of brown hue in the US
Congress who do not receive this kind of
blowback because they're not routinely
saying things that are disgusting in
public but it must be racism and sexism
and bigotry and homophobia and all the
rest leading this charge of course is
aoc who spends every waking moment
trying to defend idiocy by suggesting
that opponents of idiocy are actually
opponents of minorities here she is
saying the same thing she says that that
criticism of Ilhan Omar if you critique
Ilhan Omar you're inciting people to
racist violence and then Ilhan Omar said
the exact same thing
image for such a transparently and
politically motivated attack on the Ohio
this is we are getting to the level with
where this is an incitement of violence
against progressive women of color and
if they can't figure out how to get it
back to policy we need to call it out
for what it is because this is not
normal this is not a normal level of
political to be or rhetoric it's
incitement its incitement against wit
against women of color incitement really
so the rule now is that if you criticize
a member of Congress who happens to be a
woman of color its incitement in that
this is the speech is violence nonsense
the EC on college campuses where people
like me go to speak on college campuses
or Michael Mobile's goes and speaks on a
college campus and suddenly people are
popping up and actually attempting
violence because speech afterall is
violence if the new standard is that
harshly critiquing somebody is
incitement to violence then you know
who's gonna be responsible for violence
Ilhan Omar not two weeks ago she
suggested that Donald Trump was not a
human
she said Barack Obama was a human but
Donald Trump is not a human which is
worse saying that Ilhan Omar said a
terrible thing about 9/11 or that she
downplayed 9/11 and that she said
terrible things about America repeatedly
or is it worse you called Donald Trump
not human to dehumanize a person by
calling them not human which was more
inciting which one here Zola Hunnam are
saying that two weeks ago
is it true that you just think that he's
more polished one is human the other is
not okay which one is more inciting that
or people pointing out that Ilhan Omar's
comments about 9/11 were at best
insensitive at best it's pretty it's
pretty incredible ALC went even further
than this again it is amazing to me that
people see her as an intellectual leader
of her party if this is the case sell
your bonds because my goodness AOC
tweeted this ad about Dan Crenshaw says
M Crenshaw is one of the people who's
been critical of Ilhan Omar's comments
about 9/11 representative Crenshaw from
Texas served in Afghanistan lost an eye
to an IE D in Afghanistan did that
defending Muslims in Afghanistan so AOC
tweets this out at Dan Crenshaw so Dan
Crenshaw had tweeted first member of
Congress who ever described terrorists
who killed thousands of Americans on
9/11 as some people who did something
unbelievable AOC responds you refuse to
co-sponsor the 9/11 Victims Compensation
Fund yet have the audacity to drum
resentment toward Ilhan Omar with
completely out of context quotes in 2018
right-wing extremists were behind almost
all US domestic terrorist killings why
don't you go do something about that so
there are about eight lies in here
number one he backs the 9/11 Victims
Compensation Fund so does Donald Trump
to the extent that even Jon Stewart has
praised the Trump administration for
their work on the 9/11 Victims
Compensation Fund number two you don't
have to co-sponsor a bill to support a
bill three she's really going to suggest
that people like Ilhan Omar are doing
more for 9/11 victims then Dan Crenshaw
who joined the military and lost an eye
to fight the people who perpetrated 9/11
that that's your take while you're
dancing on a rooftop and mixing drinks
that dude was over in Afghanistan
serving and getting his eye blown out by
an AED that's your hot take it it's
unreal it's unreal and then we're
to take these people seriously when they
protest that no they love the American
military no really they take 9/11 super
seriously no they really take terrorism
seriously by the way the evidence that
Ilhan omar does not take terrorism
seriously is not just that one clip it's
that over and over and over she has said
things that make it seem like she does
not take care arisen particularly
seriously I will give you the evidence
in one second first let's talk about
hiring at your company hiring used to be
difficult multiple job sites stacks of
resumes a confusing review process but
today hiren can be easy you only have to
go to one place to get it done
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right experience
and then invites them to apply to your
job as applications come in the zip
recruiter analyzes each one spotlighting
the top candidates so you never miss a
great match zipper career is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that is
zip recruiter comm slash daily wired Dai
ly WI re zip recruiter comm slash daily
wires hip recruiters indeed the smartest
way to hire if you want to upgrade your
business there's really only one company
that you should be using for your hiring
that is zip recruiter comm slash daily
wear and give em a try for free at zip
recruiter comm slash daily Wire hey so
aloha Omar is protesting the no no no no
no no no no all of this is taken out of
context I am really not downplaying nine
let the only reason you're saying I'm
downplaying 9/11 is because I'm Muslim
and you hate Muslims that's the real
reason that you're doing all this again
I will point out she is not the only
Muslim congressperson there are several
Muslim Congress people who have not
received all of these all of these
critiques there are many members of the
of the Congress who are Muslim who don't
receive this kind of blowback and yet
and yet so why is Ilhan Omar receiving
this kind of blowback well because she
has been for years saying stuff like
this so back in 2012 she did an
interview with a pretty radical TV slash
radio show in which she questioned why
exactly why exactly is it that we say
England and America
in the same way that we why don't we say
England in America in the same way that
we say al-qaida why not we played it on
the show yesterday and she did a full
clip where she where she was joking and
laughing about Hamas and Hezbollah and
al-qaeda she said that she took a class
where the professor every time he said
al-qaeda he said Oh Qaeda with like a
feeling of dread why didn't he say
England or America or the army in the
same way because those are terrorist
groups lady that's why and that's not
the only time that Ilhan Omar has said
something like this just two years ago
she wrote a piece for Time magazine it
would get to in just one second okay so
this piece in Time magazine from Ilhan
Omar in this piece she's talking much
charlottesville and here is what she
talked about with regard to the United
States here's how she can't listen to
how she characterizes the United States
versus how she characterizes Islamic
terrorism quote we must confront that
our nation was founded by the Jenna was
founded by the genocide of indigenous
people and on the backs of slaves that
we maintain global power with the tenor
of neocolonialism so first off virtually
every aspect of that statement is wrong
the quote-unquote genocide of indigenous
people was disease brought over
centuries early earlier by Europeans
from a variety of different countries
disease is not a genocide the Trail of
Tears was not a genocide the Trail of
Tears was an evil act by the United
States government it was not a genocide
and it happened after the foundation of
the United States the nation was not
founded by the genocide of indigenous
people that's a lie and when she says
that our nation was founded on the backs
of slaves slavery was an evil part of
America's Founding also it did not exist
in the north part of the United States
members of the North were very much
opposed to slavery there's a big fight
over it in the Declaration of
Independence and it is also possible
that an evil thing that was a part of
America's history was not actually the
foundation of the country the foundation
of the country was the ideas as I've
said many times I say this in my new
book the right side of history the Great
Divide right now in the West is between
people who think like Ilhan Omar and
people who have respect for the history
of Western civilization people who
mischaracterized Western civilization
has based on hatred and fear and racism
and all of the great ideas of the
Declaration and the Constitution were
just a bunch of nonsense and then there
are people who
recognize that the ideas of the
Declaration and the Constitution are
wonderful terrific ideas that were not
always fully lived up to by human beings
nonetheless she says all that and then
she says we maintain today global power
with the tenor of neocolonialism
neocolonialism she's gonna need to
explain where we have settled in
Afghanistan and Iraq
she's going to have to explain where we
settled when we were bombing the Serbs
on behalf of the Croats during the
Yugoslavian war she's going to have to
explain where we settled when we were
defending Saudi Arabia from the
predations of Saddam Hussein where is
the colonialism exactly so she says all
that okay that's bad enough but then she
follows up with this our failure to
reconcile these facts and our failure to
take overt action to correct mistakes
further deepen the divide our national
avoidance tactic has been to shift the
focus to potential international
terrorism are you getting all of this in
other words America's had brutally
racist terrible place and because we
don't want to confront the fact that
America is a brutally racist terrible
place we make up this international
terrorist threat we focus on the
international terrorist threat so we
don't have to focus on the threats here
at home you know like white supremacy
and the evils of racism and all that so
we just sort of make it up which
obviously this is a person who takes
races who takes terrorism SuperDuper
seriously
she takes terrorism so seriously that
she characterized in 2016 in a letter to
a judge trying to get a bunch of
terrorists who had joined Isis off the
hook she characterized their actions I
mean talk about downplaying talk about
downplaying here is how she
characterized people trying to join Isis
in 2016 quote young men who made a
consequential mistake oh is that what
happened it was a consequential mistake
you know like shoplifting or a drug bust
they tried to join Isis hey she said
about this we must alter our attitude
and approach to these young men she said
a long-term prison sentence for one who
chose violence to combat direct
marginalization is a statement that our
justice system misunderstands the guilty
ah I see
so terrorists people who tried to join
up with Isis they're only doing so
because America's really bad and it's
marginalizing people and if we sentenced
those people to long jail terms
we're marginalizing them even further
but we're supposed to believe she took
9/11 super seriously
she takes terrorism really seriously
it's pretty
astonishing stuff and the fact that
Democrats have come to her defense on
the basis of your inciting violence
against her if you quote her my goodness
or that Dan Crenshaw is somehow less
patriotic than Ilhan Omar after losing
an eye in combat and being a Navy SEAL
it's just insane and it's insulting but
I guess this is what the democratic
party wishes to become I guess the
democratic party wishes to become the
party of people who rant and rave about
how terrible America is routinely and
then when called upon it suggests that
this is incitement against people of
color it's just it's just disgusting and
honestly it is just gross AOC should be
ashamed of herself
Ilhan Omar should be ashamed of herself
Rasheeda Talib should be ashamed of
herself but apparently there is that I
guess there is no reason I guess there's
there's no reason for them to be ashamed
after all the media will cover for them
so it's it is pretty amazing it is
pretty amazing and it's pretty
terrifying
okay so meanwhile they there's a big
story that came up yesterday with regard
to The Daily wires own Michael Knowles
as I said earlier when you hire somebody
to put out a hit presumably the person
should fulfill their duty but a parent
you can't get good people these days on
college campuses anyway
University of missouri-kansas city
Michael was speaking the speech was
titled men are not women this apparently
is a very controversial thing over at
University of Missouri Kansas City so in
the middle of his speech a bunch of the
protesters get up and they walk out but
they don't all walk out for long one of
them pops back through the door carrying
a SuperSoaker
that contained glitter laced it's liquid
unclear what the liquid was apparently
it smelled like bleach but this person
pops through the door and starts
shooting the super soaker at Michael at
which point one of the police officers
in the room who obviously should get
some sort of tryout with the Chiefs
takes down the perpetrator with a strong
arm bar I mean this is a solid tackle
right here
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so good times over there
good times over there and and Michael
handled it with aplomb he was he was
totally fine you know thank God this
sort of stuff happens on on campuses all
too often but that's pretty astonishing
stuff then the media covered it is those
a mere allegation Oh allegedly somebody
popped through the door and shot
something at Noel's who's on tape guys
it was on tape and that does demonstrate
how crazy things have become on campus a
campuses have become a disaster area now
most campuses are not like this I visit
lots and lots of campuses but the fact
is I also have better security than old
studs I mean whenever I speak because
campuses are aware of the kind of
controversy of causes they have lots and
lots of security so nothing like this
has ever gotten close to me but Noel's
had a little less security and
protesters decide to do something like
that if that gets in Knowles's eyes
obviously it's a big problem this is
what comes of the mentality that says
that speech is violence so Michaels
speech is a form of violence you can use
violence against his speech if you use
speech against Ilhan Omar than that is a
form of incitement to violence
amazingamazing terrible mentality okay
coming up we'll get you President Trump
on illegal immigration because there's a
breaking story that's getting a lot of
plane I'm not sure exactly why first
code names deception gadgets it might
seem like something out of the movies
but these are just some of the essential
components of being a spy most spies are
actually ordinary forgettable people
which makes them all the more dangerous
so what does it really take to be US by
every single week the podcast original
espionage tells the stories of the
world's most incredible undercover
missions and how those covert operations
succeeded or failed find out the real
world spy tactics required to
impersonate exploit infiltrate the most
confidential places in the world you'll
be fascinated by the story of KGB
operative Vasily Milken who risked his
life hiding highly classified material
from Russian secret services and
bringing it to the West you'll be
astounded by the life of Morton storm a
former Islamic radical left the religion
to work for the Danish security and
intelligence service as a spy in Islamic
militant circles search for and
subscribe to espionage wherever you
listen to podcast is really terrific
I've listened to a bit of it again
search espionage or visit podcast.com
slash espionage to listen right now this
is really cool stuff and it
blow up a lot of your preconceptions
about what exactly espionage constitutes
go check it out right now
search espionage or visit podcast.com
slash espionage to listen right now go
check it out okay
so president Trump is is now being
ripped upon because there was a proposal
that was made inside the White House
that would have directed a lot of the
illegal immigrants who could not be
absorbed by Border Patrol they'd have
enough beds the White House had thought
about directing those illegal immigrants
to sanctuary cities and send them to
democratic areas and let the Democrats
deal with the fallout from illegal
immigration if they won't actually give
us the money that we need to fund the
border wall or the beds according to the
Washington Post White House officials
have tried to pressure US immigration
authorities to release T teen detainees
onto the streets of sanctuary cities to
retaliate against President Trump's
political adversaries according to
Department of Homeland Security
officials and email messages reviewed by
The Washington Post Trump administration
officials have proposed transporting
detained immigrants to sanctuary cities
at least twice in the past six months
once in November as a migrant caravan
approached the u.s. southern border and
again in February amid a standoff with
Democrats over funding for Trump's
border wall one of the districts looked
at was House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
districts in San Francisco the
administration also considered releasing
detainees in other Democratic
strongholds the White House officials
first apparently broached the plan in a
November 16th email asking officials at
several agencies whether members of the
caravan could be arrested at the border
and then bused to small and mid-sized
sanctuary cities places where local
authorities have refused to hand over
illegal immigrants for deportation the
White House told it told ice but the
plan was intended to alleviate a
shortage of detention space but also
served to send a message to Democrats
the attempt at political retribution
raised alarm within ice with the top
official responding that it was rife
with budgetary and liability concerns
and noting that our PR risks as well
after the White House pressed again in
February Isis legal Department rejected
the idea as inappropriate and then
rebuffed the administration a White
House official and spokesman for DHS
sent nearly identical statements to the
post on Thursday indicating the proposal
was not under consideration this was
just a suggestion that was floated and
rejected which ended any further
discussion the White House statement
said Nancy Pelosi's office blasted the
plan her spokeswoman Ashley Etienne said
the extent of this administration
cynicism
and cruelty cannot be overstated using
human beings including little children
as pawns in their warped game to
perpetuate fear and demonize immigrants
is despicable frankly I'm confused by
Pelosi's reaction I am I don't
understand the reaction if the idea is
that illegal immigrants coming into the
country provide no threat and should be
placed in in areas where the resources
are available sanctuary city seemed like
a pretty good place for that LA has
thousands of illegal immigrants living
here and lots of resources and it's a
sanctuary city same thing in San
Francisco I am again I am constantly
amazed at the hypocrisy of a media that
went along with Barack Obama shutting
down open-air World War two memorials in
the middle of a government shutdown just
to prove to people he could make people
suffer and the media went along with
that oh well he has to shut memorials
doesn't it yeah he has to shut memorials
because government shutdown man doesn't
matter that it's open air doesn't matter
World War two vets can't get in he's if
Barack Obama has to make people suffered
and the shutdown I guess that's the way
this is going to go I also don't
understand why it would be markedly
worse on a moral level to send illegal
immigrants to cities where they are
going to be treated really well
presumably minna-san see Pelosi sitting
where they're gonna be treated really
well as opposed to small border towns
that are being overwhelmed with the
number of illegal immigrants and don't
have the resources there why is it
better for these folks to be shipped and
let off a bus in the middle of a small
town in Texas than to be shipped to
other places and be let off the bus
there it's it's confusing to me I mean
what why does Nancy Pelosi actually have
a problem with illegal immigrants being
sent to San Francisco in fact I'm old
enough to remember because I'm more than
five years old when one city in
California called Murrieta objected to
having illegal immigrants sent to the
city and they tried to stop the buses of
illegal immigrants that were being bused
to the city and the media covered this
as though the people who were protesting
a racist so which is it if Nancy Pelosi
doesn't want illegal immigrants sent to
her city is she a racist just like these
folks from Marietta or does she have
rational concerns about the impact of
illegal immigration on her district in
the same way these people from URI
edited here's a clip from Murrieta it's
circa 2014 this is Obama this is Obama
time
and listen now the media cover these
people from Marietta who do not want
thousands of illegal immigrants bused
into their small town community chanting
go back home a wall of protesters
blocked the road into the Murrieta
Border Patrol station not understanding
these migrants were all from Central
America tempers flaring one protester
spitting at an immigration right support
the anger continued hours after the
buses had left anger that many in this
town do find embarrassing
these are kids I mean your heart goes
out to him okay well there is truth to
the idea that people overreact to
illegal immigration in their area but I
don't see why Nancy Pelosi gets to do it
and people from your ad don't I don't
understand why it I mean listen to the
media coverage there they seek out the
people who are the most vile the people
who are spitting at people the people
who are shouting at the dead children
and that's the people they seek out
Nancy Pelosi says don't ship people to
my town that's terrible that's cynical
it's cruel why is it cynical and cruel I
don't understand San Francisco is an
extraordinarily rich area so what does
Nancy Pelosi objecting to exactly and
the media are suddenly objecting to
presidents using the power of their
office to punish their political
opponents now here's my view of the
situation illegal immigrants should be
let off in towns that have the resources
to deal with them if those are border
towns letting me border towns if they're
not border towns then let them not be
border towns but in reality none of
these illegal immigrants should be being
released into the general population at
all what we should be having are enough
beds at the border to take care of these
people and it is the Democrats fault
that those beds are not available
specifically because Democrats want
people released into the general
population Democrats are pushing at
catch-and-release if Democrats push
catch-and-release it doesn't seem
unreasonable to me for the Trump
administration to say okay well then you
get to deal with the consequences of
catch-and-release as opposed to these
people in small border towns who didn't
sign up for this you sign them up for
this well maybe you ought to bear the
the impact the human impact of illegal
immigration meaning a strain on your
local
resources now I understand why people
see that as a cynical political move by
the Trump administration it is a cynical
move by the Trump administration what I
don't understand is how they those same
people cannot see it as cynical for
Nancy Pelosi to oppose funding necessary
at the border and then object when
people are sent to her town how can you
have it both ways I am confused by this
to be frank if you are a sanctuary City
and you are saying that you're not even
going to report to ice when you legal
immigrants show up in your town and
commit crimes then why do you object to
more illegal immigrants being sent to
your town it's pretty amazing
according to the Washington Post the
White House believes it could punish
Democrats including Pelosi by busing ice
detainees into their districts before
their release according to to DHS
whistleblowers one of the whistleblowers
spoke with the post several DHS
officials confirm the accounts they
spoke on the condition of anonymity to
discuss internal deliberations again why
do Democrats view it as a punishment
why aren't emma Kratz like great we want
more of these people we can take care of
them better than you can wouldn't that
be the smart political play here
according to these two DHS officials
who's a senior Trump advisor Stephen
Miller who discussed the proposal I'll
be interested to see how all the
late-night comedians treat this home
it's absolute cruelty to ship illegal
immigrants to LA and San Francisco
whoo-hoo-hoo but I thought the goal was
to get to LA or San Francisco for a lot
of these folks wouldn't it be better for
us to just bust them there directly
actually Matthew albuns his Isis acting
deputy director immediately questioned
the proposal in November he said his
acting deputy I was not pressured by
anyone at the White House on this issue
I was asked my opinion I provided it my
advice was heated which is also true the
proposal itself I am saying is
politically understandable the
Democratic response is not politically
understandable and also the Trump
administration didn't do it because of
liability issues presumably homeland
security officials said the sanctuary
City request was unnerving and it
underscores the political pressure Trump
and Miller have put on ice and other DHS
agencies at a time when the president is
furious about the biggest border surge
in more than a decade one congressional
investigator said it was basically an
idea Miller wanted that nobody else
wanted to carry out by the way that's
not what I'm hearing from inside the
White House I'm hearing was actually
somebody else who originally proposed
this what happened here is that Stephen
Miller called people at ice said if
they're going to cut funding you've got
to make sure you're releasing people in
lo C's districts and other congressional
districts apparently the idea was not
presented to Ronald Vitiello the
agency's acting director the day after
the nomination was rescinded President
Trump said he wanted to put someone at
tougher over at ice according to a
person in may Davis deputy assistant to
the president deputy White House policy
coordinator the idea was raised by one
or two principals that if we are unable
to build sufficient temporary housing
Caravan members be bused to small and
mid-sized sanctuary cities there's not a
White House decision on all of this one
of the DHS officials said it was
retaliation to show them your lack of
cooperation has impact I think they
thought it would put pressure on those
communities to understand I guess a
different perspective and why you need
more immigration money for detention
beds a formal legal review was never
completed so this thing didn't even go
very far nonetheless the very idea is
deeply offensive I'm wondering why
Democrats think that's offensive really
if you're not gonna provide the
detention beds I'm under I am confused I
am frankly I'm confused okay in just a
second we are going to get to the latest
on Julian Assange plus we'll jump into
the mailbag first it is time to move on
to my all-time favorite underdog success
story movement watches first of all they
make great watches movement watches you
see this magnificent you see this
magnificent piece of wrist wear hey
check this out it is it is spare it is
minimalist and it tells me the time and
it looks great movement was founded on
the belief that style shouldn't break
the bank they've sold almost 2 million
watches worldwide by bringing quality
designs at fair prices the watches are
just spectacular as you see I wear one I
have two of them my wife has one my
parents have one I get them for
everybody because they're really great
and they don't cost me an arm and a leg
you guys know I'm all about supporting
ground up entrepreneurs who work hard
for what they want that's why I love
movement so much they're a true success
story
it makes wearing their products that
much more meaningful they came up and
made up a name for themselves and one of
the most established markets in the
world
they reached exponential growth which is
absolutely incredible for you get such a
young team movement watches are all
about looking good while keeping it
simple they don't tell you how many
steps you've taken or blow your wrist up
with text messages movement watches
start at just 95 bucks you're looking at
$400 for the same quality from a
traditional brand clean design minimal
really quality products movement has
sold almost 2 million watches in over
160 countries get 15% off today with
free shipping and free returns by going
to MDM
t-dot-com shapiro movements launching
new styles on their time on their site
all the time check out their latest @m b
mt comm go to mV mt comm slash appear o
get 15% off and join the movement
alright got a lot more coming up for you
in just a second first you're gonna have
to go over to daily wire comm and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wear get all
sorts of goodies when you do two
additional hours of this show every day
terrific guests later today Colonel
Allen Westen lieutenant colonel Allen
West will show up and will talk about
all of the issues of the day Michael
Mills will stop by to tell us about his
harrowing experience being being
attacked actually in a classroom they
make fun of it but doesn't sound like a
lot of fun we'll talk with him a little
bit later today about all of this you
got all that kind of stuff
when you subscribe over at daily wire
comm and when you spend $99 a year for
the annual subscription you get this the
very greatest in all beverage vessels
look at this the leftist tears hot or
cold tumbler how much are people
enjoying it they're enjoying it so much
they're going out and taking pictures of
their beverage vessels now is the time
of the week when we give a shout out to
one of our many daily wire subscribers
today Kevin Wrangler USMC on Twitter
thank you for supporting what we do in
this photo
Kevin's left his tears tumblr is keeping
him company on the links you will notice
that the turf is a luscious cream I
assume that's because Kevin has been
watering the grass with the contents of
his leftist Cheers tumbler which has
been overflowing ever since Bibi
Netanyahu was reelected earlier this
week Kevin thank you for being a
subscriber we really appreciate it also
when you subscribe you don't only get
the tumbler you also get early access to
our Sunday special with features Lauren
Chen this week all sorts of wonderful
stuff go check it out right now
over at daily wire.com also subscribe at
YouTube or iTunes please leave us a
review it always helps we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so let's talk for just a second
about the latest on Julian Assange so
Assange was arrested yesterday the the
head of WikiLeaks was arrested he was
tossed out of the Ecuadorian Embassy
after he started releasing government
documents apparently the guy is just a
turd and when I say he's a turd I mean
he literally was taking feces and
smearing it on the wall before he left I
don't know what the obsession is with
weirdos and feces but um odd so he did
that at the Ecuadorian Embassy and then
the Ecuadorians were like yeah man you
you smeared poop on the walls you gotta
go and not just leave so the British
came in and they arrested him and now
they may deport him to the United States
they may extradite him to the United
States for trial it is unclear whether
he will be convicted the charges under
which he is being charged attempted
hacking may not hold up in court we will
find out soon enough but it is
fascinating to see who is running to his
defense a tulsi gabbard who has been
very very warm toward russia very warm
towards Syria for years she condemned
the arrest of Julian Assange she called
the arrest of threat to journalists she
said the arrest of Julian Assange has
meant to send a message to all Americans
and journalists be quiet behave toe the
line where you will pay the price really
he's not American and he's not a
journalist so there are a couple of
problems with that particular statement
also president the ideas that Trump is
providing a threat to journalists by by
arresting Julian Assange why are members
of the Obama administration celebrating
all of this most of the members of the
Obama administration are very very happy
that Assange was arrested some of them
came out of the woodwork yesterday and
said listen we tried to get him on
hacking we didn't have enough to get him
on hacking now we do so good so it's
interesting to see the political
breakdown here there are folks on the
it's also funny to see who on the Left
has sort of flipped on massage so
Hillary Clinton came out yesterday she
said Assange must now answer for what
he's done she was Secretary of State
under Obama when they didn't go after a
songs really and when Barack Obama
granted clemency to to Chelsea Manning
who was the person funneling American
classified information to Asajj they
didn't take Assange WikiLeaks Manning
very seriously
here's Hillary Clinton now she's
fighting mad why well because Assange
helped make her lose in 2016 obviously I
I wait and see
what happens with the charges and how it
proceeds but the bottom line is he has
to answer for what he has done at least
as it's been charged I do think it's a
little ironic that he may be the only
foreigner that this administration would
welcome to the United States okay it is
it is pretty amazing how the left has
flipped on him by the way it's amazing
how the right flipped on him in the
middle of the 2016 election where he
have certain Fox News host who spent a
lot of time defending Julian Assange
from charges that he was in fact a
person who had endangered American
national security which by the way he is
a person who had endangered American
national security okay one more store
and then we'll get to the mailbag so
there's this wild story from the Boston
Globe
they ran a 1200 word op-ed from a guy
named Luke O'Neill a boston-based
freelance journalist and a regular
contributor to The Boston Globe opinion
section his piece called on people to
taint the food of Republicans he said at
one point the original op-ed suggested
that one of the one of the biggest
regrets he had in his life was not
pissing in Biddle in Bill Kristol salmon
in the middle of the Iraq war and his
the end of his piece he suggested that
patriotic waiters should somehow taint
the food of Christian Nielsen he said
keep Christian Nielsen unemployed and
eating GrubHub over her kitchen sink as
for the waiters out there I'm not saying
you should tamper with anyone's food is
that could get you into trouble you
might lose your serving job but you'd be
serving America and you won't have any
regrets
years later how delightful this person
was then suspended by the globe and then
he was angry at the globe for suspending
him he has every right to be angry at
the globe for suspending him they knew
what they were printing they edited it
so I don't feel bad for the globe the
globe deserves everything it gets but it
does betray a certain mentality at no
point did I ever think that it was okay
did anyone on the right that I'm aware
of ever think that it was okay to defile
the food that Barack Obama ate or that
Eric Holder ate things have gone
completely mad really completely mad
okay time for some at mailbag questions
so let's mailbag it up here all right
James says hi Ben I found myself
wondering recently how I can
simultaneously believe the following two
statements man was made in God's image
the line between good and evil
through the heart of every human being
how do you score man's capacity for evil
with the divinity of our souls well
there are several interesting spiritual
takes on this particular question the
traditional two mystic take is that evil
is a lack of good it is a diminished
good so God creates good and then we
because we have free will diminish that
good and that's what evil is that is one
view of what evil is another view of
what evil is is that God made us
effectively in two parts he made the
animal side of us the animal side of our
soul this is the the Kabbalistic view
the jewish Kabbalistic view and then he
and that is all of our desires which can
be used for perversion or they can be
used for a channel toward good and then
he and then there's the divine spark
that he put within all of us which is
our creative faculty our ability to
choose that's the part of us that is
good but we have to use that good in
order to pursue good or because we're
given free well we can use that good to
pursue evil the Jewish view is that we
have what we call the HR Hara and the HR
at ov we have we have drives to do good
we have drives to do bad and those are
implanted with us because we have
creative capacity and freewill so God
did create human beings with the
capacity to do evil but he did not force
us to do evil he encourages us to choose
good what makes us human is the fact
that we have that choice without the
presence or possibility of evil there is
no choice indeed you then become a
deterministic mechanism that always
chooses good that's what the angels are
in Jewish theology they're their
messengers that the word Moloch in
Hebrew is both messenger and also angel
the idea being that angels are
effectively just forces in the world
that have a singular purpose and do not
have the capacity to choose Justin says
Ben do you think illegal immigrants if
allowed to vote would vote along the
lines of their Christian values and not
the left if true what would the
Democrats do then well I think that what
the record tends to show is that illegal
immigrants or people who are fresh
immigrants from Central America and
Mexico that people tend to vote Democrat
for the first generation then they tend
to move toward the middle over time
second-generation Latino immigrants tend
to vote more Republican which is what
you've seen in places like Texas if they
are given tremendous benefits if people
are given tremendous benefits and do not
integrate or assimilate then they tend
to vote Democrat for a very long period
of time which is what you see in
California also it's true that the
California Republican Party treated
Latinos very differently than
Texas Republican Party Texas was much
more welcoming California was not as
welcoming and and so you've seen the
disparate impact of that in in voting
patterns and he says hey Ben do you
think the Attorney General should be
elected rather than appointed by the
president it just seems that Attorney
General's could always be portrayed as
having motives in protecting the
president of which appointed them to
that position with this solve any of the
scrutiny Barr is facing for opening this
investigation thanks Andy well no we
don't have a a fourth branch that would
create a fourth branch this was actually
the question with regard to special
investigators special special counsels
Kenneth Kenneth Starr was appointed
under the special counsel act he was
independent of the president he couldn't
be fired without congressional
permission and this created a situation
where the executive was not in control
of its own folks the theory of the
unitary executive that is expressed by
Justice Scalia so well is that we have
three branches of government not four
you can't have somebody working for the
executive but really working for the
legislature that's not the way any of
this work that's why you have
congressional investigative bodies you
want to investigate from Congress you
can do that it's the balance of power
that allows us to check power from
Congress and not make it the supreme the
supreme branch and it's the executive
that is checked by Congress so having a
elected Attorney General who is free to
do whatever they want that person will
be political too I don't believe that
anybody is completely apolitical
the Attorney General would then be the
most powerful person presumably in
America because they could investigate
the president if they didn't like the
print let's say you invite a that you
elected a democratic AG and a Republican
president then all you would get is a
bunch of a bunch of a bunch of
investigations of the president many of
them poorly motivated let's say that you
had an AG who was elected who was the
same party as the president well then
you have exactly the same problem Oprah
says hello Ben should the US leave the
UN what are the repercussions of leaving
the UN yes the United States should
defund the UN and leave the UN and
bulldoze the building and build
apartment buildings on it yes okay the
UN is a terrible idea it was always a
terrible idea there's no rationale for
countries that are run by evil human
beings to have the same weight in the UN
General Assembly as the United States
there's no reason to suggest that Russia
should be on the UN Security Council
having veto power over issues in which
it has a direct hit
direct negotiations with Russia are a
better idea than the UN Security Council
the UN is a is a mockery and a sham and
if you want to create a League of
democracies create a League of
democracies create alliances without
regard to this false notion that there's
a family of Nations there is no family
of Nations there are good nations in
terms of leadership there are bad
nations in terms of leadership to
pretend that they are on an equivalent
plane is absurd and that's why you see
these ridiculous stories all too often
with like Iran on the women's Rights
Council or something Dillon says is
there any is there any non religious way
to explain the difference between humans
and animals is there any way to argue
that humans are special without relying
on God if not then how can non-religious
people be convinced that humans are more
valuable than animals or how can they be
convinced that God is the reason behind
what separates us
thanks well this is one of the questions
that I ask in my new book by seller the
right side of history the number one
year a Times bestseller the my answer
here is know that if you are a complete
scientific materialist there is nothing
that distinguishes us from a fly let
alone from monkey so why is the capacity
for reason is just a more complex firing
of neurons and there is nothing more
moral about that per se now there are
people who say that humans are more
important than animals because we have
the capacity to reason but as I
mentioned in the book even the capacity
to reason is only morally beneficial
because the capacity to reason is seen
as something higher something morally
good where are you getting that morality
from you're not getting it from
evolutionary biology nothing in
evolutionary biology suggests that a
value attaches to the use of reason as
opposed to the use of force Spencer says
hey man I'm 20 years old I'm starting to
pick up musical instruments and playing
the piano for less than two months I'm
itching to start the more difficult
pieces what are your suggestions for
learning to play difficult classical
pieces like sonatas practice um you just
have to practice and practice and
practice and practice yeah I can play
the beginning of the moonlight sonata
that's pretty much all I can play so you
can train yourself to play specific
pieces but if you really want to get
good then you need to start from the
basics and then work your way up so that
you have a skill set and so that you're
not basically a jukebox with with one
tune on it Robert says haben after
listening to you for several years I've
gathered you grew up more or less on the
straight and narrow with extremely high
standards for yourself that's right my
question is what were the key factors in
maintaining that level of integrity
through the endlessly challenging phases
of becoming a man and what advice do you
have for parents wanting to support and
strengthen their son on that journey
thanks Donovan I think
the number one thing is my parents
always taught you have to have
responsibility for your own actions that
you will be held accountable by us or by
God and that you are doing something
that is important and good that there is
a purpose to what you are doing and that
the opposition that you face in life the
challenges the face in life make you
stronger
rather than weaker that you are for that
living on the straight and narrow is not
you bowing to external pressures living
on the straight of an arrow is you
failing to bow to external pressures
because the external pressures the lusts
that you have the things that you want
to do the hedonism you wish to pursue
those are much stronger internal and
external pressures than living on the
straight and narrow and being in control
of yourself the highest purpose that you
can that you can have as human being is
to use reason in pursuit of virtue
that's the Aristotelian idea not even
the not even the religious idea I really
believe in that precedent says hey Ben
the timing of your recent book was
perfect I'm just starting a master's
program in the great books of the
Western world
much of the program is set by the
student what great works would you
recommend focusing on thanks Preston
well it depends if I love enlightenment
philosophy I think it's really fun and
really and and really impactful
obviously I love Montesquieu I love
Locke
I even love some of the French
philosophers who I despise you know all
of that stuff is interesting I think the
under we under kind of looked at period
is the is the slightly post Middle Ages
so I think that the period from Aquinas
to Machiavelli is is rather under is
rather underserved scholastically
they're a bunch of people have written
about it but it seems to have taken a
backseat to everything Machiavelli and
beyond that stuff is really juicy I mean
Machiavelli is super juicy but the the
to Mystic period the the philosophy of
the the philosophy of Maimonides the
philosophy of Aquinas I find that stuff
to be extraordinarily valuable and and
with newfound relevance Tyler says hey
man you've talked about the seven laws
of Noah to follow in order to get into
heaven one of which is not to steal when
I was about five or six years old I was
in a gas station with my dad I stole a
small box of candy my father found out
and lectured me on why stealing is bad
quoting the Bible I wonder if this
constitutes breaking the law of not
stealing can I still get into heaven or
is my salvation over and should I live
like the hippies in the 60s Thanks love
your show and all the work you do okay
so the answer is that repentance is
always a possibility the first thing you
have to do is go back to the people
stole from if you can find them and then
repay which will be a weight off your
off your head I mean repentance in
Judaism if you commit a sin against
another person you're supposed to repent
to the person and then you can repent to
God so if you can track down which
convenience store it was it may be a lot
later then try and do it right and
you'll feel better about yourself and
that person will feel better about you
it'll be I think an amazing thing I
think gonna be an amazing it's a great
story if you do that so I would do that
if I were you also if you can't track
down the person all you can really do is
repent and one of the key modes of
repentance is acknowledging you're never
that it was wrong and you're never gonna
do it again so I think that you've
obviously done that already
Michael says hi Ben we are two law
students in the Boston area who are avid
listeners why is the legal education
industry such a hierarchy why do current
free market solutions for profit
for-profit law schools failed to stack
up against places like HLS shouldn't the
free market be able to do better than
Harvard with respect to legal education
not necessarily job prospects best might
condemn what HLS as a for-profit
institution is going to charge what they
need to charge in order to in order to
ensure that they continue to function
properly the legal education industry is
a hierarchy because most states have
laws on the books that prevent you from
taking the bar without going to an
accredited law school I think that's a
mistake I think apprenticeships should
be on the table I think you should be
able to take the bar without going to
law school I think that you should be
able to do one year without actually one
year of law school and learn the basics
of law without having to go three years
to law school and just rack up the debt
okay final final question here mark says
after watching your talk at GSU
yesterday that said well I assume that
was Grand Canyon University GCU I was
wondering what do you suggest to atheist
when balancing faith and reason are we
supposed to believe in God without a
reason sufficient for us no you don't
have to believe in God but you have to
take as valuable assumptions the same
assumptions that judeo-christian values
make and you have to understand that
what you're doing is making an
assumption about those values that's
what you have to do and you can't lie to
yourself by saying that you can reason
your way to those values or that reason
invariably carries you to those values
because I don't think that it does
assuming that reason can do too much is
just as dangerous as assuming that
reason can't do enough there's a balance
between reason and faith as I say okay
time for a quick thing that I like and
then we'll get to a thing that I hate so
things that I like today I think heaven
McCarthy did something I think was
valuable yesterday he pushed back on the
Democrats in Congress who spent their
entire time running Congress passing
useless resolutions designed to make
them look good and to virtue signal here
is Kevin McCarthy the House Minority
Leader going after the Democrats the
question more and more Americans are
beginning to ask what have the Democrats
done with their majority this friday
marks the 100th day of the new Democrat
majority a hundred days of Democrat
disappointment at this point in the last
Congress Republicans had passed a
hundred and forty one bills out of
committee and a hundred and thirty-two
out of the house by contrast Democrats
have passed 68 bills out of committee
and 97 out of the house so much for
doing the job of the people's house no
it's whatever leadership decides okay
well he is not wrong about this and it
is quite sad that Democrats have decided
that they're going to spend all of their
time passing crazy crap like the green
New Deal or Medicare for all that's
going nowhere specifically in order to
signal about stuff they have no
intention of voting for at all anyway
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
all right he said two quick things that
I hate so Maxine Waters it is
unbelievable this woman chairs a
committee particularly House Financial
Services she has been one of the most
corrupt members of Congress for
virtually her entire career well
yesterday she was doing a hearing with
Steve minuchin minuchin had already
negotiated he's the Treasury secretary
he had already negotiated with the
committee and he was gonna have to leave
after three and a half hours he'd be
happy to come back and another time he
looked up at the clock he said listen I
gotta go and Maxine Waters suddenly
decided still she persisted the strength
of Maxine Waters telling him that she
was violating I have changed the
agreement pray I don't alter it further
that's basically Maxine Waters yesterday
I've sat here for over three hour and 15
minutes I've told you I'll come back I
just don't believe we're sitting here
negotiating when I come back I
appreciate your reminding us of the
length of time other secretaries have
been here this is a new way and it's a
new day it's a new chair and I have the
gavel at this point if you wish to leave
you may can you clarify that for me
yes clarify though so if you wish to
leave you may okay so what we're
dismissed is that correct if you wish to
leave you may leave
you may go well then you want plea
please dismiss everybody I believe
you're supposed to take the gravel and
bang it that's please do not instruct me
as to hi I'm to conduct this committee
she's a crazy person
she's crazy if you want to leave you may
and he's saying like I need you to
dismiss me so that you don't hold me in
contempt when I get up and walk out of
the room like what the hell what is
wrong with you what is this nonsense
this is just as bad as when you had ill
Hunnam are questioning who is it Elliot
brand and say and saying to him so do
you support
do you support genocide and South
America he's like no and she goes I'll
take that as a yes what the hell is
wrong with these people what is wrong
with Maxine Waters just say yes you're
dismissed but she doesn't want to do
that she wants to do the I'm standing up
to power and the media treat this as
though she's standing up to power
she is the power there's no standing up
to power there he pre-negotiated the
time he would be there and then she
violated that agreement and he said can
I go and she's like you can leave if you
want he's like okay well then dismiss me
so that you don't hold me in contempt
like I'm not gonna do that
you make the decision well what what how
do we elect these people the hell is
wrong with this country my goodness
okay speaking of what the hell is wrong
with this country San Jose Airport has
decided it is deeply necessary to place
LGBTQ pride flags in the airport in
front of a chick-fil-a as though people
who work at chick-fil-a give two craps
about this the San Jose City Council
voted 11 zero on Tuesday to hang rainbow
flags in support of LGBTQ people and
pink blue and white flags for
transgender rights at or near a
chick-fil-a due to open in May at San
Jose International Airport
what's spiteful garbage human beings San
Jose City Council and this is the
equivalent it really is the equivalent
of there's a gay bakery that opens in a
small Midwestern town and the City
Council votes to put a bunch of crosses
up on flags across from the gay bakery
trick filet has not discriminated
against gay people the owner of
chick-fil-a dan Kathy Beck's traditional
marriage we are six years after he made
a statement about it and they are still
do
the spiteful nonsense where chick-fil-a
is deeply evil because the owner holds a
different position on traditional
marriage and homosexual sin that's where
we are as a country I'm so glad that the
San Jose City Council has solved all of
their problems and now they're going to
try and shame what the employees of the
local chick-fil-a how often do you think
Dan cathy is gonna go there you think
Dan Cathy is gonna stand in the window
and then stare angrily out the window at
the gay flags what do these people think
they're accomplishing the answer is
nothing they think that they are
suckering their own population into
believing that they've done something
meaningful by merely virtue signaling
what the stupidest possible methodology
what idiocy
okay we'll be back here later today for
two more hours if you subscribe you get
that if not then we will see you here on
Monday have a wonderful weekend I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey it's Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show you know Confucius
said if you want to know the truth you
have to use the proper names for things
can anyone deny that the left has made
that almost impossible whether it's
calling the FBI spying spying or calling
Julian Assange is spying journalism they
always get it wrong I'm Andrew Clavin
that's on the Andrew Klavan show